all right well the competition is
heating up for worst movie of 2012 just
can't hide it from you guys I figure you
should know what kind of review you're
getting into ghostwriter spirit of
vengeance or so I personally wasn't a
fan of the first ghostwriter I got out
of that movie my friend and I looked at
each other we were like did that movie
sucker well yeah it sucks that was
before I did YouTube videos and now we
are here for the sequel alright so Ghost
Rider spirit of vengeance Nicolas Cage
plays Johnny Blaze a guy who is cursed
and possessed by a demon or whatever so
when he's in the presence of evil people
he turns into this big flaming Skeletor
on a bike that actually sounds like it
could be one of a hundred and fifty two
ways of Awesome instead we have the
directors of cranky giving us this movie
Craig wasn't a great movie by any means
when I saw it it was way over hyped but
I was like alright yeah for that kind of
high-octane no substance whatsoever a
movie that goes from point A to point Z
I like five hundred miles an hour it
works for that and now the director of
that ADHD fest has to take characters
that are tacked on to mythology and make
an actual cohesive movie instead of
doing that he does crank with Marvel
characters namely Ghost Rider and before
any of you think this [ __ ] fest sounds
good it's not it's actually really
horrible at this point I have hung my
hat up on Nicolas Cage I was like you
were great in the rock buddy but we rest
it now I actually had some hope for this
movie because interest L was in it I
loved address album he is fresh off
winning a Golden Globe for the show
Luther he killed it as stringer bell in
the wire and now he's in this piece of
[ __ ]
Idris you're better than that man I know
cuz I've seen it I think Gaius Julius
Caesar from Rome this dude's usually a
great actor now he plays Satan in this
movie and you're just like I've seen you
in better - and it appears that Satan
plays a little MTG himself because he
turns this guy into the blood Lord of
VAS cough only instead of a vampire he's
a zombie in addition to his other
creature types and now he has deadly
allure giving him death touch until end
of turn and by end of turn I mean end of
movie which does not come soon enough
and before you think this sounds cool it
isn't Magic the Gathering that's cold
it's moving then at a point in this
movie I started to laugh because they go
meet all these monks and I hear this one
monk all I doing here I was like holy
[ __ ] is that Connor MacLeod from the
clan MacLeod
Rayden from Mortal Kombat this movie has
gotten a lot more awesome in a really
really horrible way yeah it didn't get
any better and you take the editing in
this movie it just edited really weird
you saw that scene in a trailer where
he's like pissing fire yeah that's the
least of the problems that kind of [ __ ]
is in this movie where it's just like
it's like a monster movie this big Ghost
Rider with his big flaming heads doing
[ __ ] and then imagine like Pikachu comes
on screen for one second it's like oh
what how does that have to deal with
that's just weird because you doesn't
come on screen but I'm saying it's like
that the best part is the unintentional
comedy in this movie like when the
devil's getting all decrepit and gross
he starts sounding like mama for telly
from the Goonies mama yeah that was cool
didn't mean for it to be cool or funny
but it made me laugh in the end was this
movie dog [ __ ] oh you betcha
one big flaming bag of dog [ __ ] worst
movie of the year yeah probably so far
and later on today part 3 of the year
viewers movie Awards is going to be up
on ENTV I'll put annotations for one and
two here and three when it comes out
have you watched the you reviewers movie
Awards so far I hope you guys are
enjoying it what do you think of it
comment below let me know and check out
part 3 when it's up just saying and as
always if you liked what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more